Ben is going to be temporarily replacing Bryce. I say every once in a while on the podcast that we do have to test out different co-hosts, you know, in case Bryce takes a tumble. Temporarily as far as Bryce knows. Of course, of course, like way better, way better. Like your subscriptions will double at least. I really like it. Honestly, it's my first conference both as attendee and speaker. The conference is awesome. So we're recording this at the end of the second day. Honestly, a really, really fantastic experience so far. I know, spreading the love for functional programming patterns and...
本将暂时顶替布赖斯。我在播客中偶尔会说过，我们确实需要测试不同的联合主持人，你知道的，以防布赖斯摔倒。就布赖斯所知而言是临时的。当然，当然，像好得多，好得多。就像你的订阅量至少会翻倍。我真的很喜欢它。老实说，这是我第一次以与会者和演讲者的双重身份参加会议。会议太棒了。所以我们是在第二天结束时录制这段内容的。老实说，到目前为止是一次非常非常棒的体验。我知道，散播对函数式编程模式的喜爱，以及……
Hang on, this thing is actually a find if, or this thing is a count if, or that's a rotate. But definitely changes the way you think about code. So it's about shifting the way you approach code and design. You could imagine some god-like voice saying, and then there was the elementary identificator. We started with I. What about?
等等，这个东西实际上是一个条件求和，或者这个东西是一个条件计数，或者那是一个旋转。但它绝对改变了你对代码的思考方式。所以这关乎改变你接近代码和设计的方式。你可以想象某种神圣的声音在说，然后就有了初级标识符。我们从I开始。那么呢？
What do you mean, what about? It's about ducks, right? Ducks? It's not about ducks. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 140 recorded on July 18th, 2023. My name is Connor. And today with my co-host Ben Dean, we record live from CPP North 2023 in Toronto, Canada. We interview several different speakers, Vincent Zaozao, Victor Ciara, Tristan Brindle, and Andreas Weiss. We are here live from C++ North, CPP North. I still messed it up. It's all right. With bending,
什么叫那么呢？是关于鸭子的，对吧？鸭子？不是关于鸭子的。欢迎收看第140期ADSP播客，录制于2023年7月18日。我是康纳。今天和我的联合主持人本·迪恩一起，我们在加拿大多伦多2023年北美C++大会（CPP North 2023）现场录制。我们采访了几位不同的演讲者，文森特·扎扎奥、维克托·恰拉、特里斯坦·布林德尔和安德烈亚斯·韦斯。我们是从C++北美大会现场进行直播，CPP North。我还是搞砸了。没关系。有本·迪恩，
it is live 2023. Today is July 18th, second day of the conference, and you have finished both your talks. You gave one talk, Calendrical C++, It is live 2023. Today is July 18th, second day of the conference. And you have finished both your talks. You gave one talk, Calendrical C++, yesterday on Monday. And you just finished your keynote today, Optimizing for Change. It was absolutely fantastic. How's the conference been and how have your two talks been? The conference has been great. My two talks have both been great.
这是2023年现场直播。今天是7月18日，会议的第二天，你已经完成了两场演讲。你做了一场演讲，历法C++，这是2023年现场直播。今天是7月18日，会议的第二天。你已经完成了两场演讲。你昨天（周一）做了一场演讲，历法C++。你刚刚完成了今天的基调演讲，关于变化的优化。绝对太棒了。会议感觉怎么样，你的两场演讲感觉怎么样？会议很棒。我的两场演讲都很棒。
The Calendrical one was, that was the fifth time, I think the fifth or fourth time I've given that talk, so that was, that's a really fun talk, you know. It was originally scheduled later in the week, but with things being swapped around
关于历法的那个，那是第五次，我想是第四次还是第五次我做那个演讲，所以那是一个非常有趣的演讲，你知道的。它原本安排在周后期，但由于有些调整，
with some folks had travel issues, it got swapped to yesterday. And then the keynote this morning, you know, I have this thing when I'm up on stage, I don't really remember what happens up on stage. I think it went well. I think I hit all the points I meant to hit.
有些人遇到了旅行问题，它被调到了昨天。然后今天早上的基调演讲，你知道的，我上台时有这样一种情况，我真的不记得在台上发生了什么。我觉得进展顺利。我想我讲到了我打算讲的所有要点。
And people seem to enjoy it. So that's a win. I personally thought, I mean, I can't speak for everyone at the conference. I thought it was fantastic. The links will be in the show notes, but probably actually by the time, I think keynotes, I don't actually know. The links, they might go up fairly soon. Keynotes typically go up first, so the keynote talk will definitely be linked.
人们似乎很喜欢它。所以这是一次胜利。我个人认为，我是说，我不能代表会议上的所有人。我认为它非常棒。链接会放在节目简介里，但可能实际上到那个时候，我想基调演讲，其实我不知道。链接，它们可能会很快上线。基调演讲通常最先上线，所以基调演讲肯定会有链接。
And I think, I don't actually think your calendrical C++ one is out from C++ Now yet, but by the time this airs, it probably will be because I know that C++ Now is slowly rolling out. So there will be some links. Some will be live. Some will be live in the future. Outside of your two talks, what have you enjoyed most? Is it the food? Has it been another talk?
而且我想，其实我不认为你的历法C++已经在C++ Now上发布了，但等这期节目播出时，它可能已经发布了，因为我知道C++ Now正在慢慢推出。所以会提供一些链接。有些会上线。有些未来会上线。除了你的两场演讲，你最喜欢什么？是食物吗？是另一场演讲吗？
There's been lots of good stuff here. The food is good. The food's really great. The maple tarts came out just now. We just literally, like this break session. Did you have one? I did. I had one.
这里有很多好东西。食物很好。食物真的很棒。枫糖挞刚出炉。我们刚刚，字面意思，就像这个茶歇。你吃了一个吗？我吃了。我吃了一个。
I was specifically looking for them. Apparently they, and I asked Mike about them from yesterday, and that's how I learned they'd be here right now. But the talks have been fantastic as well. Your talk, Composition Intuition, was just super fun, all about combinators. A passion project of mine. Link will be in that in the description that probably
我特意在找它们。显然它们，我昨天向迈克问过它们，这就是我怎么知道它们现在会在这里的。但演讲也同样棒。你的演讲，组合直觉，超级有趣，全关于组合子。我的一个热爱项目。链接会放在那个描述里，可能
won't be out for a couple months but uh all of them all the talks are being recorded so you'll be able to watch them online if you weren't here at the conference yeah absolutely um i've been just trying to go to talks that uh are new to me there's always a few at every conference where people you know because people make typically maybe one talk a year, maybe two, and they take them to different conferences. So there's a couple of talks here like would be at any conference that I'd seen before on YouTube or from ACCU or wherever it was given before. So I've been trying to hit talks that I haven't seen.
几个月内不会发布，但所有这些，所有的演讲都在录制中，所以如果你没有来到会议现场，你将能够在网上观看它们，是的，绝对的，嗯，我一直在努力去听那些对我很陌生的演讲，每个会议总有那么几个，人们，你知道的，因为人们通常一年做一个演讲，也许两个，然后他们把它们带到不同的会议上。所以这里有几个演讲，就像我在YouTube上或者从ACCU无论以前在哪里看过的一样，在任何会议上都会有。所以我一直在努力听那些我没看过的演讲。
I really enjoyed Victor's talk. I enjoyed Timo's talk on safety, which I had seen an earlier version of, I think, but people also have all their talks, so that was great. Victor's talk was fantastic. It was what, and? And then some tea, I think.
我真的很喜欢维克托的演讲。我喜欢蒂莫关于安全性的演讲，我想我看过早期版本，但人们也有他们所有的演讲，所以那很棒。维克托的演讲太棒了。那是，什么，还有？然后是一些茶，我想。
And then some tea? Yeah, and then, paren, paren, some, paren, paren, tea. It was about, what was it about? It was about, what was it about? It was about... Functional patterns with optional and expected. And maybe some other things I don't remember because I'm on the mic. Yeah, that was basically my recollection as well. I mean, it had an odd title.
然后是一些茶？是的，然后，括号，括号，一些，括号，括号，茶。那是关于，那是关于什么的？那是关于，那是关于什么的？那是关于……带有optional和expected的函数式模式。也许还有其他一些我不记得的东西，因为我开着麦。是的，这基本上也是我的回忆。我是说，它有一个奇怪的标题。
It could have had a different title that was like, you know, yeah, exactly what you just said. Functional patterns with optional and expected. And it alluded, there was a bit of Haskell code, talked a little bit about functional programming, my favorite kind of, you know, sprinkling code from different languages, show how we stole ideas, and
它本可以有一个不同的标题，就像，你知道的，是的，就像你刚才说的。带有optional和expected的函数式模式。它暗示了，有一点Haskell代码，稍微谈了谈函数式编程，我最喜欢的那种，你知道的，穿插不同语言的代码，展示我们是如何窃取创意的，以及
how to use them well in C++. About right? Yeah, that sounds about right to me. Alright, I think the goal is now, you are going to be my replacement for Bryce, my traditional co-host, co-host for the moment, but being replaced by Ben himself. And also, too, I keep the stats, and maybe we're probably in a bad place, because now that I realize, we're standing right in front of the coffee. We could step down into the more upholstered area where there's less hard surfaces.
如何在C++中很好地使用它们。差不多吧？是的，我觉得差不多。好的，我想现在的目标是，你要成为布赖斯的替代者，我的传统联合主持人，目前的联合主持人，但由本亲自取代。还有，我也在做统计，也许我们处境不妙，因为现在我意识到，我们正站在咖啡机正前方。我们可以走到软垫更多的区域，那里坚硬表面少一些。
That's exactly what we're going to do. And it's for the moment, Bryce, I'm going to hand the mic to Ben. Ben's going to do the interviewing. I'm going to do the audio adjusting. And the point is, Ben is going to be temporarily replacing Bryce. I say every once in a while on the podcast that we do have to test out different co-hosts, you know, in case Bryce takes a tumble. Temporarily as far as Bryce knows, yes. And that was what I was going to say.
我们正要这么做。而且只是暂时的，布赖斯，我要把麦克风交个本。本将负责采访。我来调整音频。关键是，本将暂时顶替布赖斯。我在播客中偶尔会提到，我们确实需要测试不同的联合主持人，你知道的，以防布赖斯摔倒。就布赖斯所知是临时的，是的。这就是我正要说的。
We'll see how Bryce reacts. Well, I have all the power, so if I want you to be co-host for the day, you get to be co-host for the day. I was going to say is I think you are the number two most featured guest by podcast edits, like by podcast numbers. Sean is number one. I believe when this is released, it'll be like 11 podcasts across four interviews.
我们看看布赖斯作何反应。好吧，我掌握着所有权力，所以如果我想让你当一天的联合主持人，你就能当一天的联合主持人。我本来想说的是，我认为你是按播客剪辑计算，也就是按播客期数计算，出场率第二多的嘉宾。肖恩是第一。我相信当这个发布时，大约是四个采访中的11期播客。
And I think you are at like seven or eight across two interviews. I think it's just that we talk for so long when we interview and you split it up for like maybe four or five. Like I've only actually talked to you twice, but you don't tend to have guests very frequently maybe you're wrapping that up a bit but yeah it's actually i think it's three times now because the most recent uh you and tristan that was the third we did a solo one
而我想你大概是两个采访中的七、八期。我想只是因为我们采访时聊了很久，你把它拆分成了大概四、五期。就像我其实只跟你聊过两次，但你通常不怎么经常邀请嘉宾，也许你正在结束这种状态，但是的，其实我觉得现在是三次，因为最近的那次，你和特里斯坦，那是第三次，我们做过一次单人节目
with you that was like four and then we did the you and tony live from c++, virtual 2020 or 2020. Was it virtual? It was definitely virtual, I think. I think that was the 2020. It was the first virtual conference, right? I think it was canceled in 20, and it must have been 21 when it came back. That definitely sounds right, actually, yeah. I think 2019 was the last in-person one pre-COVID. 2020 was canceled, and then 2021, I think that was completely virtual.
跟你，大概是四次，然后我们做了你和托尼从C++现场，2020虚拟或2020。是虚拟的吗？绝对是虚拟的，我想。我想那是2020年。那是第一次虚拟会议，对吧？我想20年取消了，21年回归的。听起来确实如此，是的。我想2019是疫情前最后一次线下会议。2020取消了，然后2021，我想那是完全虚拟的。
And then Tony showed up halfway through. Right, right, because we were in that, I forget the name of it. Gather Town, Gather Town. Gather Town, yes, yeah. All right, now we're hunting. We've talked to Kate Gregory and Jessica Kerr, two of our keynotes. One has spoken on Monday, Jessica speaking tomorrow. They both agreed to chat with us tomorrow. But right now they're both preparing for lightning talks, which are going to
然后托尼在半途出现了。对，对，因为我们在那个，我忘了名字。Gather Town，Gather Town。Gather Town，是的，是的。好了，现在我们在寻找。我们和凯特·格雷戈里以及杰西卡·克尔交流过，我们的两位主旨演讲者。一位在周一发言，杰西卡明天发言。他们都同意明天和我们聊天。但现在他们都在准备闪电演讲，将在
be taking place in less than 45 minutes or so. Vincent, do you want to be interviewed? All right. I'm handing the mic over to Ben. You're in charge now. And Bryce, let's hope he doesn't do too well because your tenure here could be on limited here. All right. So here we have Vincent Zalzal. You just gave a talk that I was in just now, and it was about how to write readable code. How did it go?
不到45分钟左右的时间内进行。文森特，你想接受采访吗？好的。我把麦克风交给本。现在由你负责。布赖斯，让我们希望他表现别太好，因为你在这里的任期可能是有限的。好了。这里我们有文森特·扎扎尔。你刚刚做了一场演讲，我刚才就在台下，内容是关于如何编写可读代码。感觉怎么样？
I did better than I thought I would. Really, I'm happy with how it went. And I hope that it's a nice intro talk for anyone that wants to learn to use the C++ core guidelines and choose the right parameter types, the right code that every team member can understand clearly. And, yeah, I just hope that it gets shared in the end. Right on, yeah. How's the conference been in general? I really like it. Honestly, it's my first conference both as attendee and speaker.
比我想象的要好。真的，我对效果很满意。我希望对任何想学习使用C++核心准则并选择正确的参数类型、每个团队成员都能清晰理解的正确代码的人来说，这是一个不错的入门演讲。而且，是的，我只希望最终能被分享出去。太棒了，是的。总的来说会议怎么样？我真的很喜欢。老实说，这是我第一次以与会者和演讲者的双重身份参加会议。
So I really like it. I like seeing all the people I've looked at on the Internet before, like you, actually, and listen to the podcast. So, yeah, I'm very happy and surprised actually to now be on the podcast so yeah so this is the first time you've been to any c++ conference did you say it is it is it's my first time yeah you think you're going to come back to this one or to any others yeah maybe maybe the stress level was quite, so I have to calm down first. But yeah, I think so.
所以我真的很喜欢。我很高兴能见到我在网上看过的所有人，比如你，真的，还有听这个播客。所以，是的，我非常高兴，甚至很惊讶现在能上这个播客，所以，是的，所以这是你第一次参加任何C++会议，你是这么说的吗？是的，是的，这是我第一次，是的。你觉得你还会来参加这个或其他会议吗？是的，也许，也许，压力水平相当大，所以我得先冷静一下。但，是的，我想会的。
Well, great. We have a new speaker on the circuit. We have Vincent. That's fantastic. And I'll follow up with a question. Just for the listeners, where are you based out of and what do you do for work? So I'm based in Montreal, Canada, and I work in the computer vision industry so I've done 3D reconstruction and sensor calibration so camera calibration think about removing distortion from images taking world measurements from pixels converting all of that, maybe confirming that a mechanical object is to specs, that kind of stuff.
好吧，太棒了。我们的圈子里有了一位新演讲者。我们有文森特。这太棒了。我接着问个问题。对听众来说，你常驻哪里，你的工作是做什么的？我常驻加拿大蒙特利尔，我在计算机视觉行业工作，所以我做过3D重建和传感器校准，比如相机校准，想想消除图像失真，从像素获取世界测量数据，转换所有这些，也许确认机械对象符合规格，诸如此类的事情。
So computer vision in general. Awesome. How long have you been programming C++? I've been using C++ professionally for 15 years, a little more than that before at school, say. And I've used some other languages, but mainly C++ at work. I've done some C Sharp too for two years.
所以基本上是计算机视觉。太棒了。你用C++编程多久了？我专业使用C++有15年了，上学时还要多一点。我用过其他一些语言，但工作主要用C++。我也做过两年C#。
And on the side, some MATLAB, Python, some Rust. And how modern is the C++ you get to use? What standard are you on? It depends. Unfortunately, I've been capped to C++ 14 for a very long while. So it's actually by looking at those conferences, those talks that I could keep up to date and by doing side projects and that kind of stuff. And in the last two years, I've been doing C Sharp.
业余时间用过一些MATLAB、Python、一些Rust。你用的C++有多现代化？你用的是哪个标准？这得看情况。不幸的是，很长一段时间里我被限制在C++ 14。所以实际上是通过关注这些会议、这些演讲，以及通过做业余项目之类的事情，我才得以保持最新。而在过去两年里，我一直在做C#。
So yeah, I felt almost like an imposter now not being at the forefront and not using C++ in the last two years, but I think I've kept enough up to date to be on par, at least to be a speaker. C Sharp has the benefit that Link came in, what, C Sharp 3 or something?
所以，是的，我现在感觉自己像个冒名顶替者，没有站在最前沿，在过去的两年里没有使用C++，但我认为我保持了足够的最新状态来齐头并进，至少可以作为一名演讲者。C#的一个好处是引入了LINQ，在什么版本，C# 3还是别的？
I don't know anything about C Sharp, but I know that the equivalent of C++ 20 ranges stuff has been in C Sharp for many versions now, so my guess is that you have access to that kind of stream fusion composable function stuff, which is great for C Sharp for many versions now. So my guess is that you have access to that kind of stream fusion, composable function stuff, which is great for C Sharp. We love that, right?
我对C#一无所知，但我知道C++ 20 ranges之类东西的等价物在C#中已经存在很多版本了，所以我的猜测是你可以使用那种流融合、可组合函数的东西，这对C#来说很棒，已经存在很多版本了。所以我的猜测是你可以使用那种流融合、可组合函数的东西，这对C#来说很棒。我们很喜欢那个，对吧？
Honestly, Link in C Sharp is pretty neat. I find it really nice to use. And it's, you know, the fact that you can use the dot syntax or you can use the SQL syntax if you prefer. You have like two different syntax to use that depending on which you're more comfortable with. But there are also things that I really dislike about C Sharp.
老实说，C#中的LINQ非常简洁。我发现它用起来真的很棒。而且，你知道的，你可以使用点语法，或者如果你喜欢的话可以使用SQL语法。你有两种不同的语法可以使用，取决于你对哪个更熟悉。但C#也有我非常不喜欢的地方。
So yeah, I'm glad to be back to C++ now. Cool. I need to tell you, by the way, that the global API injection pattern is usable in 14. It's not just for 17. Even though I showed it with a variable template, which is 17, you can do it with a function template
所以，是的，很高兴现在能回到C++。酷。顺便说一句，我得告诉你，全局API注入模式在C++14中是可用的。它不仅适用于17。尽管我用变量模板展示了它，那是17的特性，但你可以用带有返回类型推导的函数模板来做，
with return type deduction, right? 11 doesn't have return type deduction, so you can't specialize the function template in the same way, but it works on 14. So if you are still stuck on 14, you can still use it. I'm looking forward, actually, to look at that code, understand it calmly can still use it I'm looking forward actually to look at that code, understand it calmly
对吧？11没有返回类型推导，所以你不能以同样的方式特化函数模板，但它在14上起作用。所以如果你仍然卡在14上，你仍然可以使用它。我很期待，实际上，去看看那个代码，冷静地理解它，仍然可以使用它。我很期待实际上去看看那个代码，冷静地理解它，
and yeah I'm very curious to know because it's a very common problem having global APIs I think everybody has that problem so if there's a nice pattern that we could encapsulate and propagate it would be so nice so yeah I'm looking forward to try it
是的，我很好奇，因为这是一个非常常见的问题，拥有全局API，我想每个人都有这个问题，所以如果有一个很好的模式可以封装和传播它，那就太好了，所以，是的，我很期待去尝试它。
Cool Alright thank you so much Vincent we will definitely link would be so nice. So, yeah, I'm looking forward to try it. Cool. Awesome. All right. Thank you so much, Vincent. We will definitely link your YouTube talk when it comes out in the show notes. And if you're on the socials, I'll find you and link your stuff so people can follow you. I'm not sure if Twitter, Mastodon, Threads, you know.
酷。好的，非常感谢你，文森特，我们肯定会链接，那就太好了。所以，是的，我很期待去尝试。酷。太棒了。好的，非常感谢你，文森特。当你的YouTube演讲发布时，我们一定会在节目简介中链接它。如果你在社交媒体上，我会找到你并链接你的东西，这样人们就可以关注你了。我不确定是Twitter、Mastodon还是Threads，你知道的。
It's a confusing time for social media. But I will track you down if you have it, and we'll link it in the show notes. Thanks for being on the pod. Thank you. All right. We are going to go find, maybe we should talk to Victor. Seeing as we were talking about his talk, I see the back of his head right there. Victor, do you want to be on the podcast?
对社交媒体来说这是一个混乱的时期。但如果你有的话，我会找到你的，我们会在节目简介中链接它。感谢你参加播客。谢谢。好的。我们要去找，也许我们应该跟维克托聊聊。既然我们一直在谈论他的演讲，我看到他的后脑勺就在那儿。维克托，你想上播客吗？
What about? What do you mean, what about? Are you telling me you don't listen to ADSP, the podcast? It's about travel. It's about ducks, right? Ducks? It's not about ducks. It's about the travels of Bryce and Connor.
关于什么的？什么叫关于什么的？你是说你不听ADSP播客吗？那是关于旅行的。是关于鸭子的，对吧？鸭子？不是关于鸭子的。是关于布赖斯和康纳的旅行。
Yeah, that's true. It's a C++. Do you want to come? Or do you have to get approved by you've got to talk to Satya Nandela? Hopefully not. Hopefully not. We're going to hand Mike once again off to Ben, our replacement for Bryce. Replacing Bryce.
是的，没错。是个C++。你想来吗？还是你必须获得批准，你得跟萨蒂亚·纳德拉谈谈？希望不用。希望不用。我们要再次把麦克风交给本，我们的布赖斯替代者。取代布赖斯。
And he's doing great so far. It's not looking good for Bryce. Here you go, Ben. Well, let me tell you my travels in the last month. Yeah. You have walnut furniture. I was Slovenian. You're going to be editing this, right, Gunnar?
而且他目前表现得很棒。对布赖斯来说情况不妙。给你，本。好吧，让我告诉你我上个月的旅行。是的。你有胡桃木家具。我是斯洛文尼亚人。你会在后期剪辑掉这个，对吧，冈纳？
I mean, I think I'm going to leave that part in. That's fantastic. Let's see. At the beginning of each interview, we should roast Bryce a little bit. I love that. Okay, so Victor Chura, you're at Microsoft, right? Yep, that's what they say.
我的意思是，我打算把那部分留着。太棒了。让我们看看。在每次采访开始时，我们应该稍微吐槽一下布赖斯。我喜欢这个。好吧，那么，维克托·丘拉，你在微软，对吧？是的，他们都这么说。
And so what kind of, I mean, what's your position? What kind of C++ are you doing day to day? I'm in the IDE productivity team and the IDE experience group, and I work on tooling. Stuff I've been working on for many, many years now, even before joining Microsoft. I've always done
那么你是什么样的，我是说，你的职位是什么？你日常在做什么样的C++？我在IDE生产力团队和IDE体验小组，我从事工具开发。这些是我已经做了很多年的工作，甚至在加入微软之前。我一直在做
developer tools, SDKs, libraries, productivity stuff for devs mostly. So I keep doing that and helping to improve hopefully the tool I've been using for 20 years now. Nice. And so hopefully the tool I've been using for 20 years now. Visual Studio.
主要针对开发者的开发工具、SDK、库、生产力工具。所以我一直在做这个，并希望能帮助改进我用了20年的工具。不错。所以希望改进我用了20年的工具。Visual Studio。
Nice. And so you had more than one talk or just one talk? You had a talk yesterday here and then some tea, which was about optional, expected, functional patterns. Yep. Can you tell us a bit about that? So it was one of the talks in my long arch on spreading the love for functional programming patterns and embracing writing more clean and readable and composable code
不错。所以你有一场以上的演讲还是只有一场？你昨天在这里有一场演讲，还有一些茶，是关于optional、expected、函数式模式的。是的。能给我们讲讲吗？所以这是我关于传播对函数式编程模式的喜爱、拥抱编写更清晰、可读和可组合代码的长期计划中的一场演讲
and borrowing concepts from functional programming languages and figuring out how to use them in day-to-day C++. And most of the examples were centered around monadic extensions for standard optional and patterns in using the new standard expected. So I saw interest in the crowd. I had quite a few questions after the talk. So people seem to be interested in that kind of stuff, and that makes me happy.
借鉴函数式编程语言的概念，并弄清楚如何在日常C++中使用它们。大多数示例都集中在标准optional的单子扩展以及使用新标准expected的模式上。所以我看到了人群中的兴趣。演讲结束后我有很多问题。所以人们似乎对这类事情感兴趣，这让我很高兴。
And hopefully the talk was well received, and people will be inspired to learn more about these kind of things. I've done quite a few functional programming style of talks, so maybe I'll keep doing that. Do you use a lot of functional programming in of talks so um yeah maybe i keep doing that do you use a lot of functional programming in your day job uh not a lot but um i i i tend to be inspired by that style of of thinking and mostly by decomposing problems in that way and structuring, composing computation and structuring programs in that way. It's not something that resembles a lot in what you've seen in the slides, but definitely changes the way you think about code.
希望演讲广受好评，人们会受到启发去了解更多这类事情。我做过相当多函数式编程风格的演讲，所以也许我会继续这样做。你在日常工作中用很多函数式编程吗？演讲的，所以，是的，也许我会继续这样做。你在日常工作中用很多函数式编程吗？不多，但我倾向于受那种思维风格的启发，主要是通过以这种方式分解问题并构建、组合计算以及以这种方式构建程序。它并不像你在幻灯片中看到的那些那样高度相似，但它绝对改变了你对代码的思考方式。
So it's about shifting the way you approach code and design. I agree wholeheartedly. That is my experience as well, I would say. So C++ code won't look like Haskell code. But yeah, Connor... And it won't look like APL either, Connor. I mean, it definitely won't look like APL, but the range of stuff, you know,
所以这关乎改变你接近代码和设计的方式。我完全同意。这也是我的经验，可以说。所以C++代码不会看起来像Haskell代码。但是，是的，康纳……它也不会看起来像APL，康纳。我的意思是，它绝对不会看起来像APL，但是ranges之类东西，你知道的，
the range of stuff is getting pretty Haskell-y, if you ask me. Yeah, yeah. And I like how you did the progressive transition from rust to c++ where it was half rust half c++ mixed and and when he kept the the the captures in the lambdas in rust style and because it looked better that was cheating that was don't uh don't tell anyone but that that was the lunch break in the prior talk slot. Adding all of those slides was like over the last three days.
ranges之类东西变得越来越像Haskell了，如果你问我的话。是的，是的，我喜欢你是如何从Rust平稳过渡到C++的，那是半个Rust半个C++混合的，当你在lambda中保留了Rust风格的捕获时，因为那样看起来更好那是作弊，那是，别告诉任何人，但那是前一个演讲时段的午餐时间。添加所有这些幻灯片就像是在过去三天里完成的。
And I wasn't sure I'd have time to get all those animations, but it looked so nice. What's the name for Enumerate? And then I think, Ben, you were the only one that got it because everyone said Iota. It's Enumerate in 23, right? Exactly, yeah. But even I forget about it. For so long, I have been using Zip with Iota because it was the very, very last range adapter to get in because I believe it was quarantine.
我不确定自己是否有时间搞定所有这些动画，但它看起来太棒了。Enumerate叫什么名字？然后我想，本，你是唯一一个答对的人，因为大家都说Iota。是23中的Enumerate，对吧？没错，是的。但连我都忘了。很长一段时间里，我都用Zip加Iota，因为那是最后一个进入的ranges适配器，因为我相信那是隔离期。
It had been working for so long to change the API a little bit, but then they just decided to throw it out. They had something that was working. But anyways, it went in at the 11th hour, and it's always at the bottom of the list of the stuff that people list off. Anyways. I didn't know about Enumerate, honestly. I mean, I've never used it. I just
它为了稍微改变API已经开发了很久，但后来他们决定放弃它。他们原本有一个能用的东西。但无论如何，它在最后一刻加入了，而且它总是排在人们列出的东西的底部。不管怎样。老实说，我不知道Enumerate。我的意思是，我从没用过它。我只是
know about it from somewhere because I read cppreference.com every day. I mean, it's a weird hobby. It's a perfectly good hobby for a C++ programmer. I'm still miffed that they didn't call it zipwith.
从某处知道它，因为我每天都读cppreference.com。我的意思是，这是一个奇怪的爱好。对于一个C++程序员来说，这是一个非常好的爱好。我仍然对他们没有把它叫做zipwith感到恼火。
I actually really wanted zipwith.iota, but Sc't call it zip with. I actually really wanted like zip with IOTA, but Scala calls it zip with index, which I actually, I was having this debate with someone yesterday that they said, oh, but enumerate's the right word for it. And I was like, eh. I think index is more explicit. I mean, it's more honest in what it does.
我其实非常想要zipwith.iota，但Scala把它叫做zip with index，其实，我昨天跟某人辩论过这件事，他们说，哦，但enumerate是正确的词。我说，呃。我认为index更明确。我的意思是，它在做什么上更诚实。
Whereas enumerate, you kind of have to know what it does. Yeah, I mean, other languages, there are some other languages that call it enumerate, you kind of have to know what it is. Yeah, I mean, other languages, there are some other languages that call it enumerate, right? Yeah, definitely Python is the most popular. Rust calls theirs enumerate as well. And I think Rust kind of borrowed it from. But I think the most common, it's not like filter or map where there's almost, you know,
而enumerate，你得知道它在做什么。是的，我的意思是，其他语言，还有其他一些语言把它叫做enumerate，你得知道它是什么。是的，我的意思是，其他语言，还有其他一些语言把它叫做enumerate，对吧？是的，绝对地，Python是最受欢迎的。Rust也把他们的叫做enumerate。我想Rust是从……但我认为最常见的是，它不像filter或map那样几乎，你知道的，
a universal agreement on what it's called. Except C++. Yeah, except for C++ when it comes to map. That was also the other joke of enumerate's enumerate, filter's filter, map is transform. But I think enumerate is the most common, and then it's kind of across the board.
大家对它的名字有近乎普遍的共识。除了C++。是的，除了C++在map这个问题上。这也是关于enumerate的另一个笑话，enumerate就是enumerate，filter就是filter，map就是transform。但我认为enumerate是最常见的，而且它在各种语言中都差不多。
It's either enumerate or something kind of that every language chooses something else. But, you know, what can you do? You know, we'll learn to love it. I think it's odd, though, that Enumerate doesn't have an overload that takes a starting value because the spelling of it sometimes is almost shorter because you have to do a map with a plus one. It's almost easier to just zip with Iota because Iota has an overload that can take...
它要么是enumerate，要么是每种语言选择别的什么。但是，你知道，你能怎么办呢？你知道，我们会学会爱上它的。不过我觉得奇怪的是，Enumerate没有一个接受起始值的重载，因为它的拼写有时几乎更短，因为你必须做一个带加一的map。直接用zip with Iota几乎更容易，因为Iota有一个可以接受……
Exactly. I find that just interesting is, like, the mental arithmetic of, like, Enumerate's only useful when really you want zero or you're going to be calling a map right afterwards. Anyways, check it out in C++23, folks. Good stuff is coming. Speaking of good stuff,
没错。我只是觉得有趣的是，就像心算一样，Enumerate只有在你真正想要零或者你紧接着要调用map时才有用。无论如何，去看看C++23吧，伙计们。好东西要来了。说到好东西，
let me do interviewer now. So I'm curious. I saw a lot of folks approach you after your presentation today and I was curious, how did a lot of folks approach you after your presentation today, and I was curious, how did they embrace the combinators and all that good stuff that you showed? Did you get a lot of questions around figuring out, learning, understanding that kind of code when you see it for the first time?
现在轮到我来采访了。所以我很好奇。我看到很多观众在今天的演讲结束后接近你，我很好奇，大家在今天的演讲结束后是如何接受组合子以及你展示的所有那些好东西的？当你第一次看到那样的代码时，你有没有收到很多关于弄清楚、学习、理解那种代码的问题？
What was the reaction? I really think this is the inflection point for array languages. I can really see BQN and APL entering the top 20 languages, I think, after this. No, I'm just kidding. What are you drinking? I think there's definitely, maybe at this conference, it's more, it piques people's curiosity. I mean, Tristan, who we're about to talk to. I mean, Tristan, you can come up here.
大家的反应是什么？我真的认为这是数组语言的转折点。我真的可以看到BQN和APL在这之后进入前20大语言，我想。不，我开玩笑的。你在喝什么？我认为绝对有，也许在这个会议上，它更多的是激起人们的好奇心。我是说，特里斯坦，我们马上要和她聊。我是说，特里斯坦，你可以上台来。
Well, yeah, Tristan, come on over. Well, I'll finish answering Victor's question in a second. But Tristan asked a question, or not asked a question, but made a comment how he sees how introducing maybe these combinators not in the same library, but like how it could increase the flexibility of a ranges-like or flux-like library. And more interestingly is that I gave this same talk at Lambda Days in Poland back in June, a month ago. And that was a functional crowd. And I heard from maybe not a double-digit number of people, but I had, at the end of my talk sort of put the URLs for the
好吧，是的，特里斯坦，过来吧。嗯，我一会儿回答完维克托的问题。但特里斯坦问了一个问题，或者说不是问问题，而是发表了一个评论，关于他如何看到引入这些组合子，不是在同一个库中，而是如何能增加类似ranges或flux的库的灵活性。更有趣的是，我在6月份（一个月前）在波兰的Lambda Days做了同样的演讲。那是一个函数式编程的群体。我从大概不算双位数的人那里听到，但我有，在我的演讲结束时，基本上放了
BQM pad and try APL and a bunch of folks had like immediately gone. But I think they are so much more ready because they're already in Haskell or Scala or Clojure. So, you know, APL and BQM, it's a much smaller step. It's still a big step, but they see that and they're like, oh, cool. I want to take it for a spin. Because I think also that they're coming from Haskell. They're already familiar with a lot of these ideas, so it's less of a mental jump. But I think there's definitely, it piques people's curiosity. I don't think folks are going to be switching to a new language.
BQN pad和try APL的URL，许多人立即去试了。但我认为他们准备得要充分得多，因为他们已经在用Haskell、Scala或Clojure了。所以，你知道，对于APL和BQN，这是一个小得多的步子。这仍然是一个大步子，但他们看到后会想，哦，酷。我想试用一下。因为我认为他们也来自Haskell。他们对许多这些想法已经很熟悉了，所以心理上的跨度没那么大。但我认为这绝对激发了人们的好奇心。我不认为大家会转而使用一种新语言。
Anyways, let's bring Tristan into the conversation. Yeah, I'll just do a quick intro for Tristan. Friend of this podcast, author of Flux, Tristan Brindle, C++ trainer, based in London, right? All correct, yes. Hello. And I just realized this is the in-person trio that we just did a podcast interview, several episodes, may have been two months at this point since we released it.
无论如何，把特里斯坦拉进对话吧。好的，我简单介绍一下特里斯坦。这个播客的朋友，Flux的作者，特里斯坦·布林德尔，C++培训师，常驻伦敦，对吧？全对，是的。你好。我刚意识到这就是我们在播客采访中做过的那个人线下三人组，好几集了，自从我们发布它以来可能已经有两个月了。
We did it on Zoom, and now here we all are, plus Victor. And Victor, where are you based out of? I'm in Prague now. So look at that. We're global here. We've got a Canadian, someone in America, someone in the UK, someone in Prague. Awesome. So tell us about the conference, Tristan.
我们是在Zoom上做的，现在我们都在这儿了，还有维克托。维克托，你常驻哪里？我现在在布拉格。所以看看这个。我们是全球化的。我们有一个加拿大人，一个在美国的，一个在英国的，一个在布拉格的。太棒了。特里斯坦，给我们讲讲这次会议吧。
The conference is awesome. So we're recording this at the end of the second day. We're just about to have the lightning talks. It's been honestly a really, really fantastic experience so far. So I haven't given my talk yet that's coming tomorrow uh hopefully that's going to go well uh but so far the conference has been great and um especially the talks by uh by ben and connor and i'm not just saying that because ben's holding the microphone no pitch your talk pitch your talk for tomorrow yeah what's your
会议太棒了。所以我们是在第二天结束时录制这个的。我们马上要进行闪电演讲。老实说，到目前为止是一次非常非常棒的体验。所以我还没做我的演讲，那要在明天，希望一切顺利，但到目前为止会议一直很棒，尤其是本和康纳的演讲，我这么说不仅仅是因为本拿着麦克风。不，宣传一下你的演讲，宣传一下你明天的演讲。
talk about tomorrow so my talk tomorrow is uh it's kind of a well it's about my flux library that uh long-time listeners of adsp will already be familiar with um so it's about kind of the motivation why i wrote this new library what i'm intending what the goals are and then some sort of usage examples and some information about how you can use it and the cool things you can do. Great. So practical advice. Well, getting started advice, I guess. Anecdotally, we just interviewed you very briefly.
明天的演讲讲什么？我明天的演讲是，它有点像，嗯，是关于我的Flux库的，ADSP的长期听众对此已经很熟悉了，所以它是关于编写这个新库的动机、我的意图、目标，然后是一些使用示例以及关于如何使用它以及你能做的酷事情的信息。太好了。所以是实用建议。嗯，入门建议，我想。趣闻是，我们刚刚非常简短地采访了你。
You got listed in the guest interviewed, but your interview was all of about 30 seconds at C++ on C, which was two or three weeks ago now. And you gave the same talk, but since then, I'm not sure how many other talks, if you did a tally, mentioned or showed Flux code in their talks. I think it might have been zero other than yours. But now here we are, less than a month later, and you've had two talks at this conference outside of your own that you haven't given yet that have mentioned Flux.
你被列入受访嘉宾名单，但你的采访在C++ on C上总共持续了大约30秒，那是两三周前的事了。你做了同样的演讲，但自那以后，我不确定还有多少其他演讲，如果你统计一下，在他们的演讲中提到或展示了Flux代码。我想除了你之外可能是零。但现在我们在这里，不到一个月后，你在这次会议上有两场演讲，除了你自己还没做的那个，都提到了Flux。
I don't know if it's going to be an error. What, four? Three? Three. What was the third one? Timur, apparently. So it was, yeah, Victor's was the first. It sounds like Timur in his talk showed some Flux code. He mentioned it. He didn't show Flux. That still counts. That's zero to three.
我不知道这会不会是个错误。什么，四个？三个？三个。第三个是什么？蒂穆尔，显然。所以，是的，维克托的是第一个。听起来蒂穆尔在他的演讲中展示了一些Flux代码。他提到了它。他没有展示Flux。那也算。那是从零到三。
Is it going to be arithmetic? Is it going to be geometric? This is what happens at conferences, right? You come and then you've got, if you're a speaker, you've got a talk that you're giving and you watch talks and then things occur to you and you sort of react to the talks as you go through the conference. It happens all the time.
这会是等差数列吗？会是几何级数吗？这就是会议上发生的事情，对吧？你来了，然后你有了，如果你是演讲者，你有一个要做的演讲，你观看演讲，然后脑海中涌现想法，随着会议的进行，你对演讲做出反应。这经常发生。
Yep. So, yeah. Flux is... Spreading like wildfire. Flux is an idea whose time has come. Well, I mean, I think so. I think it's a great idea. I hope I can persuade other people of that as well.
是的。所以，是的，Flux正在……像野火一样蔓延。Flux是一个其时已至的想法。好吧，我的意思是，我也这么认为。我认为这是一个伟大的想法。我希望我能说服其他人也这么认为。
Cool. All right. I mean, should we ask? We've got Victor, we've got Tristan. Should we ask anything else while favorite talks or, you know, what should the listeners of the podcast do after listening to this episode? Again, I'm going to bust up Ben because he's standing right next to me. But genuinely, your keynote today, that was a really, really excellent talk.
酷。好的。我是说，我们该问问吗？我们有维克托，我们有特里斯坦。我们在最喜欢的演讲或者听完这期节目后播客听众应该做什么方面还有什么要问的吗？再次，我要调侃一下本，因为他就站在我旁边。但说真的，你今天的基调演讲，那真是一场非常非常出色的演讲。
Other sessions, I mean, Kate's keynote was fantastic. You don't really have to say that. You could just say, well, Kate Gregory gave the keynotes. I really, I mean, I'm just, I really enjoyed Victor's talk. I really enjoyed Connor's talk. I really enjoyed Connor's talk. You know, it's just been a great experience all round. I agree.
其他场次，我是说，凯特的基调演讲太棒了。你其实不必这么说。你大可以只说，凯特·格雷戈里做了基调演讲。我真的，我是说，我只是，我真的很喜欢维克托的演讲。我真的很喜欢康纳的演讲。我真的很喜欢康纳的演讲。你知道的，总的来说这真的是一次很棒的体验。我同意。
Victor, any final words? So most mind-blowing talk was combinators. Yeah. Unsurprisingly. Yeah. I'm still going to digest that one. And so on that one, I'm one, should I be thinking about birds? Should I be thinking about letters?
维克托，有什么最后的话吗？最震撼的演讲是组合子。是的。毫不意外。是的。我还在消化那一个。关于那一个，我有一个问题，我应该去想鸟类吗？我应该去想字母吗？
How should I form a coherent view of combinators, Connor? You should be thinking of composition patterns. Hooks. Yeah, but what name should I use? I'm thinking I'll just go with birds. I mean, birds is fine. I, like, the strongest semantic attachment of this concept to a word that I have is combinators, specifically the combinatory logic combinators that I showed in that Venn diagram. But birds is fine.
康纳，我该如何对组合子形成一个连贯的看法？你应该去想组合模式。钩子。是的，但我应该用什么名字？我想我还是直接叫鸟类好了。我是说，鸟类挺好。我，就像，这个概念对一个词的最强语义依恋是组合子，具体来说是我在那个维恩图中展示的组合逻辑组合子。但鸟类挺好。
Composition patterns is fine. Honestly, like, the birds, the letters, they're all attached, and it's more just the pattern of, like, I didn't mention this in the talk, but, like, think if you have a binary function and a unary function, a function that takes two arguments and a function that takes one argument. How many different ways can you compose those? Is this, like, a Catalan number problem? No, it's not really a Catalan. It's just, like, start to think, like, we covered the B1, the blackbird,
组合模式挺好。老实说，就像，那些鸟类，那些字母，它们都是附带的，这更多只是这样一种模式，就像，我在演讲中没提到这个，但是，想象一下，如果你有一个二元函数和一个一元函数，一个接受两个参数的函数和一个接受一个参数的函数。你可以用多少种不同的方式来组合它们？这就像是卡塔兰数问题吗？不，不是真正的卡塔兰数。这就像是，开始思考，就像我们讲过的B1，黑鸟，
which is apply the binary first and then pass that to the unary. The psi combinator is apply the unary twice to each argument and then pass the results of those to the binary. The S combinator is apply the unary to the second argument, but leave the first argument alone. The sigma is the reverse of that. Apply the unary to the first argument. Okay. So you just like combinatorially explore the space there, and each one is a different combinator.
也就是先应用二元函数，然后把结果传给一元函数。Psi组合子是对每个参数应用两次一元函数，然后将这些结果传给二元函数。S组合子是对第二个参数应用一元函数，但保持第一个参数不变。Sigma则相反。对第一个参数应用一元函数。好吧。所以你就在那里以组合方式探索空间，每一个都是不同的组合子。
And what's interesting is the first time I came across it where the S is reversed, where you're applying the unary function to the first argument instead of the second, the second one is the S combinator. It's in the S-K-I combinator logic. But I hadn't seen anywhere where it was applied to the first until Marshall Lockbaum's I programming language, which he did in 2012, where they call S in J hook, and then he implemented what he called the back hook, which is basically just that missing combinator, which is what it doesn't have a letter.
有趣的是，我第一次遇到它时，S是反过来的，你将一元函数应用于第一个参数而不是第二个，第二个就是S组合子。它在S-K-I组合逻辑中。但我没见过哪里把它应用到第一个参数上，直到马歇尔·洛克鲍姆（Marshall Lockbaum）在2012年编写的I编程语言中，他们在J语言中把S叫做hook，然后他实现了他所说的back hook，基本上就是那个缺失的组合子，它没有字母。
So I made one up, and I just called it sigma because there were some Greek letters. And so S has the corollary sigma, and then D, which I never explained, has a corollary delta. But just this, if you start to play this game of, it's the same thing with algorithms, when you have find, which takes a value, find if, which takes a unary predicate, adjacent find, which takes a binary predicate. It's like, there are
所以我编了一个，我叫它sigma，因为有一些希腊字母。所以S有推论sigma，D我从未解释过，有推论delta。但只要这个，如果你开始玩这个游戏，算法也是一样的，当你拥有find（接受一个值），find_if（接受一元谓词），adjacent_find（接受二元谓词）。就像，有些
certain algorithms that are missing the unary predicate version. It's like the standard model in particle physics. You anticipate new combinators based on symmetries and missing things. The arrow can point the other way.
算法缺少一元谓词版本。这就像粒子物理学中的标准模型。你根据对称性和缺失的东西来预测新的组合子。箭头可以指向另一个方向。
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, someone was saying... New elements, new particles. Exactly, the periodic table. Did you say that earlier? It's like a periodic table where originally
是的，完全正确。是的，有人在说……新元素，新粒子。没错，元素周期表。你刚才说过这个吗？这就像元素周期表，最初
there were gaps but you infer the existence. It's this... We were having a similar conversation yesterday about this book, where I was the one that mentioned the book called Mind in Motion by Barbara Tversky,
存在空白，但你推断出了它们的存在。这就是这个……我们昨天就这本名为《行动中的思维》（Mind in Motion，芭芭拉·特弗斯基（Barbara Tversky）著）的书进行过类似的对话，
which she makes this sort of push for this idea that like thought is not based on language like Noam Chomsky says, but it's based on visualizations. And like she described a couple of things of like taking this text or, you know, if it's these combinators, but then you visualize it, you put it in this kind of hierarchy and then you see missing gaps and it's
她提出了这样一种观点，即思想不是像诺姆·乔姆斯基（Noam Chomsky）所说的那样基于语言，而是基于可视化。她描述了几种方法，比如拿到这段文本，或者如果你用的是这些组合子，然后将其可视化，把它放入这种层次结构中，接着你就能看到缺失的空白，然后就会发现
like i would never have seen that just by looking at the lambda definitions and say oh s like where is the where's the version of s that has it over here but like you see this graph that's missing like a node and then you're like shouldn't something be there and then you're just like reverse engineering what's missing it's really so one one of the takeaways I got from your talk was that it's a bit like if you start off just writing for loops, right? And then you kind of get to recognize the patterns of, oh, hang on, this thing is actually a find if, or this thing is a count if, or that's a rotate. And then you start to reckon, hang on, that's actually what I'm doing. And I think it's probably the same thing with these combinators
就好像我光看 lambda 定义是绝对发现不了这一点的，我会想：“S 在哪儿？那个把 S 放在这里的版本在哪儿？”但当你看到这个图表时，会发现它少了一个节点，然后你就会觉得：“那里是不是应该有什么东西？”接着你就在对缺失的部分进行逆向工程。真的，我从你的演讲中得到的收获之一就是，这有点像你一开始只是在写 for 循环，对吧？然后你开始识别出这样的模式：“噢，等等，这个东西实际上是一个 find_if，或者这个东西是一个 count_if，又或者是一个 rotate。”接着你开始意识到：“等一下，这正是我在做的事情。”我想这些组合子也是同样的道理
that you just write the lambda and it does the right thing but then you do it enough and you start to recognise the patterns of, hey, no, actually I'm composing these functions in this way. And the hidden combinators are an interesting thing where you have algorithms like inner product and similar things where you don't actually see it but it's part of how it's constructed it's part of you know and how you use it so it's it's it's not visible you have to understand and to identify the pattern so it's it's it's hidden it's not visible it's it's not a function or a macro that you see there like
你只需写出 lambda 表达式，它就能正常工作，但当你写得够多时，就会开始识别出这样的模式：“嘿，不对，实际上我是在以这种方式组合这些函数。”隐藏的组合子是一个有趣的现象，你会遇到一些算法，比如内积以及类似的东西，你虽然看不到它们，但它们是构建方式的一部分，是你如何使用它的一部分，所以它是不可见的，你必须去理解并识别这种模式，所以它是隐藏的，是不可见的，它不是那种直接摆在你面前、一眼就能看到的函数或宏
in in your face you have to understand it i've got a final question for you connor do you have a copy of of the book the combinatorial logic volume one it is not in print and it is actually it's very hard to find on the internet however i do have not a legally obtained copy because my eyes go sideways. Of the first volume, I have both a PDF version and some other, I have no idea what the dot, sort of,
你必须去理解它。我有一个最后一个问题想问你，康纳，你有《组合逻辑》第一卷这本书的副本吗？这本书已经绝版了，在网上其实非常难找到。不过，我确实有一份“来源不太合法”的副本，因为我的眼睛会斜视。对于第一卷，我既有 PDF 版本，还有其他一些版本，我完全不知道那个后缀是什么，
it's not Moby, but it's something. So I do have a copy. If you look hard enough, it is online. And that's actually where, like, I never found an article that mentioned the elementary combinators.
它不是 Mobi 格式，但类似某种格式。总之我确实有一本。如果你仔细找找，网上其实是有的。也就是在那里，我从来没有找到过一篇提到基本组合子的文章。
And I haven't read the text in full because it's very dense. But I skimmed through it. And in chapter five, that's when they actually get to, like, introducing the elementary combinators and i haven't read the text in full because it's very dense but i skimmed through it and in chapter five that's when they actually get to like introducing the different combinators and there's this great section where you know it starts introducing them and it's like you could imagine some like god-like voice saying and then there was the elementary identificator we started with i and then it goes on like paragraph to paragraph and i'm reading this just being like oh my goodness like like this is fantastic i mean probably other people would be like what is he he talking about? But like for me personally, you know, it's probably the similar when you're doing your calendar research and you stumble
而且我没有完整地阅读这本书，因为它太晦涩了。但我大致浏览了一下。到了第五章，他们才真正开始引入基本组合子。而且我没有完整地阅读这本书，因为它太晦涩了，但我大致浏览了一下，到了第五章，他们才真正开始引入不同的组合子。这里有一个很棒的部分，它开始介绍这些内容，给人的感觉就像是你可以想象某种神一般的声音在说：“随后，我们有了最初的恒等标识符 I”，然后它就这样一段接一段地讲下去。我读到这里时就在想：“哦天哪，这太棒了！”我的意思是，其他人可能会觉得：“这他在说些什么呀？”但对我个人而言，（这感觉）可能就像你在做日历研究时偶然
across some factoid and you're just like, oh, this is great. You know, it's, uh, it's what we do for fun. We love it. We absolutely love it. I got to say the combinator that I miss most is Kestrel. I find myself needing that all the time, especially in type-based programming. Kestrel is the K combinator, correct? Yeah, const in Haskell. Yeah, that is I mean, when I first saw it,
碰巧发现了某个琐碎的事实，然后你就会觉得：“哦，这太棒了！”你知道的，这就是我们为了好玩而做的事情。我们热爱它，绝对热爱它。我得说，我最想念的组合子是隼鸟（Kestrel）。我发现自己无时无刻不在需要它，尤其是在基于类型的编程中。隼鸟就是 K 组合子，对吧？对，Haskell 里的 const。对，那就是……我的意思是，当我第一次看到它时——
I think I said that in the talk, I and K, my first thoughts were both of these, like, this is stupid. Who needs a function that returns its argument and then K is just throwing one away and keeping the other. Like, who needs that? Yeah, you don't realize the need for it when you first see it cold until you actually start using combinators and you figure it's incredibly valuable.
我想我在演讲中也说过，对于 I 和 K，我最初的想法都是：“这太蠢了。谁会需要一个返回其参数的函数，而 K 只是把其中一个扔掉，保留另一个？谁会需要这种东西？”是的，当你第一次生疏地看到它时，你不会意识到它的需求，直到你真正开始使用组合子，并发现它是如此的无价。
They are very, very useful, and it only becomes apparent once you, like Tristan was saying, once you start to name these or just recognize these patterns, they're all over the place. And I don't think I actually said it in the talk, but like my, one of my sort of evolutions of my thought or like I, my assertion is that like these composition patterns are like more fundamental than like binary mathematical operations.
它们真的非常非常有用，一旦你——就像特里斯坦（Tristan）刚才说的——一旦你开始给它们命名或者仅仅是识别出这些模式，就会发现它们到处都是。而且我想我当时在演讲中没有说的是，我思想演变的过程之一，或者说我的一个断言是：这些组合模式比二元数学运算更为基础。
Like we learn symbols for plus, symbols for time, symbol for divide and minus. And then we stop there and we don't do anything for min and max, except if you learn APL or BQN or J. But, like, these things, they apply to, you know, the space of math and numbers, but not really outside of that, whereas composition applies to every kind of function. Like, passing an argument, you know, the same argument twice, that applies, there's no, like, domain that that's limited to, right? Like, any function you can do that with, and, you know, maybe people prefer their parentheses and stuff, but, like, once you start to see it, it's like, it's like when you
比如我们学习加号的符号、乘号的符号、除号和减号的符号。然后我们就停在那里了，对于求最小值和最大值，我们什么也不做，除非你学过 APL、BQN 或 J。但是这些东西，它们适用于数学和数字的空间，但在那之外却不太适用，而组合则适用于各种类型的函数。比如传递一个参数，（你知道，传入相同的参数两次），这是适用的，没有哪个领域是局限于此的，对吧？任何函数你都可以这么做，而且，也许人们更喜欢他们的括号之类的东西，但一旦你开始看到它，这就好比你在
see something in another language, and then you come back to C++, and you miss it. Like, when I am coding without these little patterns, it breaks my heart, especially, too, even in Haskell, like, you've got to use four characters, five characters for some of these things. Like, yeah. Like symbol symbol is it's massive. Like the fact that W or C like flip or join are just a single character really influences the way that you will reach for these things. Cause it's, cause it's just one thing. It's just one character. Yeah. I mean, in Haskell, I'm, I come from Haskell originally before, you know, you came from Combinators to this. I came from Haskell to this. And so I know them as Flip and Const and Join, as you say.
另一种语言中看到了某种东西，然后你回到 C++，就会开始怀念它。比如，当我在没有这些小模式的情况下编写代码时，我的心都要碎了，尤其是即便在 Haskell 中，你还得为其中某些东西使用四个字符、五个字符。就像，对。像符号符号，这太庞大了。W、C、flip 或 join 仅仅是一个单字符，这一事实极大地影响了你伸手去使用它们的方式，因为它们只需要一个东西，只需要一个字符。是的。我的意思是，在 Haskell 里，我是……我最初来自 Haskell，在……你知道的，你是从组合子接触到这些的，我是从 Haskell 接触到这一块的。所以我所知道的名字正如你所说的那样，是 Flip、Const 和 Join。
So now I've got to rewire my brain to think about the birds instead. I'm being a terrible host now because Victor asked a question and then, you know, it's like a... Well, also, I don't know how long you wanted to go with this recording or when the lightning talks are. terrible host now because because victor asked a question and then you know it's like yeah well also i don't know how long you wanted to go with this recording or when the lightning talks are uh lightning talks are in 17 minutes so we'll probably do 10 more minutes but we'll we'll we'll thank tristan and victor and we will pivot to to andreas andreas vice uh you work at woven planet thank you tristan and thanks thanks victor thanks tristan i i'm standing here for bryce on the You work at Woven Planet. Thank you, Tristan. Thanks, Victor. Thanks, Tristan. I'm standing in for Bryce on the podcast.
所以现在我必须重新连线我的大脑，转而去思考那些鸟类（组合子名称）。我现在是一个糟糕的主持人，因为维克托问了个问题，然后……嗯，另外，我不知道你这次录音想持续多久，或者闪电演讲是什么时候。糟糕的主持人，因为维克托问了个问题，然后，你知道的，这就像是……好吧，另外，我不知道你这次录音想进行多久，或者闪电演讲是什么时候。呃，闪电演讲在 17 分钟后开始，所以我们大概再进行 10 分钟，但我们会感谢特里斯坦和维克托，然后我们将把话题转向安德烈亚斯（Andreas）。安德烈亚斯·维斯，你在编织星球（Woven Planet）工作。谢谢你，特里斯坦，谢谢维克托。谢谢特里斯坦，我在这里代替布赖斯（Bryce）参加……你在编织星球工作。谢谢你，特里斯坦。谢谢维克托。谢谢特里斯坦。我是在播客中代替布赖斯来的。
Anything bad or any, you know, you want to say anything bad or how great of a co-host Ben is. Would you like to hear Ben more as a co-host? Of course, of course. Like, way better, way better. Like, your subscriptions will double at least. Oh, Bryce. If that's the truth, we might need to see some numbers.
有什么不好的或者任何……你想说点什么不好的，或者本（Ben）是一个多棒的联合主持人吗？你希望更多地听到本作为联合主持人吗？当然，当然。超级棒，超级棒。你的订阅量至少会翻倍。哦，布赖斯。如果这是真的，我们可能得看一看数据了。
But if that's the truth, let's hope if this one gets twice as many views as we do regularly, we might have to consider this. So, Andres, you gave a talk here yesterday. Can you tell us about it? Yeah, I was talking about interface design, the famous Scott Myers guideline, make your interfaces easy to use correctly, hard to use incorrectly. And I was demonstrating some techniques,
但如果这是真的，让我们希望这次的观看次数能达到我们常规的两倍，那样的话我们可能就得考虑一下了。那么，安德烈亚斯，你昨天在这里做了一个演讲。能给我们讲讲吗？好的，我当时讲的是接口设计，也就是斯科特·迈尔斯（Scott Myers）著名的准则：让你的接口易于正确使用，难以错误使用。我当时演示了一些技术，
how you can use the type system to make that work for you. Very nice. Something very close to my own heart. What C++ standard were you targeting with that talk? That's a good question. I think I had mostly stuff that should work with 17. I think the only thing from 20 that I had in there was the designated initializers,
展示了如何利用类型系统让这一点为你所用。非常棒。这非常符合我的心意。你那个演讲针对的是哪个 C++ 标准？这是一个好问题。我想我讲的东西大部分应该适用于 C++17。我觉得里面唯一用到 C++20 特性的是指定初始化器（designated initializers），
which is a feature that I like very much. But that was just one example. So most of the stuff should work with not quite that recent standards as well. Great, great. Yes, I think pretty much most people are close to 17, if not on 17. A lot of folks at conferences are now.
这是我非常喜欢的一个特性。但那只是其中一个例子。所以绝大多数内容在稍微没那么新的标准上应该也能正常工作。太棒了，太棒了。是的，我想几乎绝大多数人都在接近 C++17 的版本，即使没有完全使用 C++17。现在会议上的很多人都是这样。
A lot of folks are wanting to get to 20. I mean, I'm on C++23, but we will link. That's because I'm in research. I mean, technically, I'm on C++23 when it suits me and then Circle when C++23 doesn't suit me. But we will leave a link in the show notes to, I think there's a JetBrains one. And is there a separate ISO C++ or like C++ foundation? Sorry, JetBrains what?
很多人都想升级到 C++20。我的意思是，我使用的是 C++23，但我们会放一个链接……那是因为我在做研究。我的意思是，技术上讲，当它适合我时，我使用的是 C++23，而当 C++23 不适合我时，我用的是 Circle。但我们会在节目shownotes中留下链接，我记得有一个 JetBrains 的……还有一个单独的 ISO C++ 还是说 C++ 基金会？抱歉，JetBrains 什么？
JetBrains survey that does the actual analysis. And I think probably the median is C++17. Yeah, I think so. So how's the conference in general? Any favorite talks? Oh, yeah, it's very nice. It's my first time in Toronto, actually. I really like Kate's keynote.
JetBrains 的调查做过实际的分析。我想中间值大概是 C++17 吧。是的，我也这么觉得。那么总体感觉会议怎么样？有什么最喜欢的演讲吗？哦，是的，非常棒。这其实是我第一次来多伦多。我真的很喜欢凯特（Kate）的主旨演讲。
That was great, yeah. That's the kind of talks, like she really pulls that off like no other. So, yeah, I really enjoyed that one. Great. Well, we've really enjoyed that one. Great. Well, we've got lightning talks tonight. Are you giving a lightning talk? Oh yeah, I'm giving a lightning talk
太棒了，是的。那是那种类型的演讲，她真的能把那种效果发挥得淋漓尽致，无人能及。所以，是的，我真的很喜欢那场。太棒了。好了，我们真的很喜欢那场。太棒了。好吧，我们今晚有闪电演讲。你要做闪电演讲吗？哦，是的，我要做闪电演讲，
and my lightning talk has more slides than my main talk so that's going to be interesting. How many slides? 60. 60? There you go, you've got six minutes. Are you kidding? Your lightning talk has 60 slides?
而且我的闪电演讲的幻灯片数量比我的主演讲还要多，所以这将会很有意思。有多少张幻灯片？60张。60张？好吧，你只有六分钟时间。开玩笑吧？你的闪电演讲有 60 张幻灯片？
You've got to stretch it to six minutes. Is that like 55 slides of animation or something? Yeah, there's some animation in there and some stuff that you're not supposed to read. It's only there for the effect. I am very intrigued. Give us a little teaser. I mean, the lightning talks will be recorded
你得把它压缩到六分钟内讲完。那是大概 55 张充满动画效果的幻灯片之类的吗？是的，里面有一些动画，还有一些本来就不需要你仔细阅读的内容，它们存在只是为了营造效果。我太好奇了。给我们透露一点预告吧。我的意思是，闪电演讲会被录制下来，
and will be online as well at some point, but for the listener, give them a little, and also for us because we're about to watch them, give us a little teaser of what we can expect. Yes, it's about complexity, runtime complexity analysis, how you do that. Hmm, interesting. I support the notion of having slides for effect and not talking about them at all. I like to do that in some of my talks occasionally I mean, six minutes is what?
而且在某个时候也会上线，但对于听众来说，给他们透露一点，而且也为了我们，因为我们马上就要去观看了，给我们一点剧透，看看我们可以期待些什么。好的，它是关于复杂性的，运行时复杂性分析，你是如何做这一点的。嗯，有趣。我赞成那种为了视觉效果而准备幻灯片却完全不讲它们的做法。我偶尔也喜欢在自己的一些演讲中这么做。我的意思是，六分钟是多少？
360 seconds? Yeah, well, Lani talks of five minutes if you can stretch that I just went to six minutes because you said 60 slides but yes Right, I mean, good luck So it's five seconds a slide then?
360秒？是的，好吧，闪电演讲是五分钟，如果你能撑得下的的话……我刚才说六分钟是因为你说了 60 张幻灯片，不过是的。好吧，祝你好运。那平均一张幻灯片只有五秒钟喽？
Right, yeah. I did a couple of test runs. Like my best one, I was 30 seconds under. The worst one, I was 30 seconds over. So it's... Oh, you're right in the ballpark there. Oh, we're going to see Tony for the first time tonight. He's hosting Lightning Talks, right?
对，是的。我做过几次彩排。我表现最好的一次比规定时间少了 30 秒。最差的一次超了 30 秒。所以……哦，那你正好在这个范围内。哦，我们今晚要第一次见到托尼（Tony）了。他在主持闪电演讲，对吧？
This is true. For folks that have not met Tony Van Eerd in person, he is local to Ontario, not exactly Toronto. He lives outside, I believe, in Kitchener, which is just outside Waterloo. If folks have seen the new Blackberry movie, that's where that takes place, Kitchener-Waterloo. And he famously does not make any appearances
确实如此。对于那些还没有在现实中见过托尼·范·埃尔德（Tony Van Eerd）的人来说，他是安大略本地人，但严格来说不算是多伦多的。我记得他住在外面基奇纳（Kitchener），就在滑铁卢（Waterloo）郊外。如果大家看过那部新的黑莓（Blackberry）电影，那就是故事发生的地方，基奇纳-滑铁卢。而且众所周知，他不会在
until after his talk because he's holed up in his hotel working on his slides. I think actually he's even maybe been feeling a bit under the weather. He's been unwell, I think, last couple of days. So I hope he's feeling well again and able to do lightning talks tonight. So it'll be a good sign if he's hosting the lightning talks because that means he's feeling well enough to host them. But if we don't see him tonight, we're hopefully going to see him tomorrow. And then hopefully we'll be able to grab dinner with him afterwards because we're on day two tomorrow's day three and then the conference wraps so it's going to be a short a short debut uh from from tony yeah um anything to to say more under address or is that
他的演讲结束之前露面，因为他一直闷在酒店里赶工他的幻灯片。我觉得实际上他最近可能甚至感觉身体有点不太舒服。过去几天他好像一直有点不舒服。所以我希望他现在感觉好点儿了，能够主持今晚的闪电演讲。如果他来主持闪电演讲，那将是一个好兆头，因为那意味着他感觉好多了，足以胜任主持工作。但如果我们今晚见不到他，我们希望明天能见到他。然后希望之后我们能和他一起吃晚饭，因为明天是第二天，后天是第三天，接着会议就要闭幕了，所以这是个很短、很短的……呃……托尼的首次亮相。是的，嗯……还有什么要补充的吗，安德烈亚斯，还是说……
it also tell the listeners uh where are you based out of and uh you know yeah how'd you get here oh yeah i mean we know we took the plane probably. Swam. Yes, I'm currently still based in Munich, Germany. So also still helping with running the user group there for C++. And yeah, I just flew in first time flying into Canada and I'm having a blast. It's a great conference. Cool.
顺便告诉听众，你常驻在哪里，以及……是的，你是怎么来这里的？哦，是的，我的意思是，我们知道我们大概是坐飞机来的。游过来的。是的，我目前常驻德国慕尼黑。所以我同时还在协助运营当地的 C++ 用户组。是的，我刚坐飞机来，这是我第一次飞往加拿大，我玩得很开心。这是一个很棒的会议。酷。
Did you have any travel problems? There were several folks who had connection problems through New York. Yeah, no. I had a direct flight so fortunately I was spared. Alright. And that's enough about travel. Yeah, enough about travel. If Bryce isn't here, we're nipping that in the bud. And I guess, so if you're in Germany,
你遇到什么出行问题了吗？有几个人通过纽约转机时遇到了转机问题。没有。我坐的是直飞航班，所以很幸运地避开了。好的。关于旅行的话题就到这里吧。是的，关于旅行的就够了。如果布赖斯不在这里，我们要把这个苗头掐死在摇篮里。我想，如果你在德国，
last question. I assume probably on your horizon is the Meeting C++ conference, because that's just a stone's throw away in Berlin. Are you going to be there, and are you going to be speaking? Unfortunately not this year. So they had to, usually the conference was always in the end of the week, and this year they had to put it in the beginning of the week,
最后一个问题。我猜你的日程上接下来应该是 Meeting C++ 会议吧，因为那在柏林，离得非常近。你会去参加吗，并且会做演讲吗？很遗憾今年不会。因为他们通常会议总是在周末结束时举行，而今年他们不得不把它安排在周初，
and now it actually overlaps with the ISO meeting in Kona. And because of the huge time shift from Kona, it's basically impossible to get there in time unless you leave the ISO meeting early. So I probably won't be able to make it. I didn't submit any talks because of that. Interesting, interesting. And so that means, well, I guess the CFP, I was going to say this would be a great opportunity if there's some new speakers because probably it's going to take out of the rotation a bunch of speakers,
现在它实际上和科纳（Kona）的 ISO 会议时间重合了。而且由于科纳的时差巨大，除非你提前离开 ISO 会议，否则基本上不可能按时赶到那里。所以我可能去不了。因为这个原因，我没有投递任何演讲。有趣，有趣。这意味着，好吧，我想说征稿（CFP）……我本来想说如果有一些新演讲者的话，这将是一个绝佳的机会，因为这可能会让大批演讲者退出轮换，
but probably the CFP is closed long by now. They just started the voting on the talks last week. So, yeah, CFP is closed. Well, hopefully we'll get to see some new speakers at the conference, because, yeah, if it collides with the committee meeting, I don't know what the overlap is, but it's definitely like 25% or 50% of committee members have also given a talk at some point in time. All right. All right.
但可能征稿早就截止了。他们上周才刚刚开始对演讲进行投票。所以，是的，征稿已经截止了。好吧，希望我们能在会议上看到一些新的演讲者，因为，是的，如果它与委员会会议冲突，我不知道重合度是多少，但绝对有大约 25% 或 50% 的委员会成员也在某个时间点做过演讲。好的。好的。
Is that a wrap for now? That's a wrap for now. We'll be back on day three. We've got two people lined up. We definitely wanted to get Kate, who's been mentioned, and Jessica, who's giving the keynote tomorrow morning. I think we mentioned earlier, they're both given lightning talks alongside Andreas here. So we're going to get excited for those. And I mean, the listener, probably this is going to be mid-episode.
现在就这样收尾吗？现在就先这样。我们将在第三天回归。我们已经安排好了两位嘉宾。我们非常想请到刚才提到的凯特，以及明天上午发表主旨演讲的杰西卡（Jessica）。我想我们之前提到过，她们俩都将和这里的安德烈亚斯一起做闪电演讲。所以我们对此感到非常兴奋。我的意思是，对于听众来说，这可能是在节目中间。
So they're going to snap of the fingers and they're listening to Kate right now. Yeah, we have to wait another 12, 18 hours and it's coming right up for you. Thanks, Andreas. Thank you for having me. Awesome. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to any of the topics or talks that we talked about in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, thoughts, or questions.
所以他们只要打个响指，现在就能听到凯特的节目了。是的，我们必须再等 12 到 18 个小时，节目马上就会为你呈现。谢谢你，安德烈亚斯。谢谢你们邀请我。太棒了。请务必查看你的播客应用或访问 ADSPthepodcast.com 上的节目shownotes，获取我们在今天节目中讨论的任何话题或演讲的链接，以及可用于留下评论、想法或问题的 GitHub 讨论区链接。
Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed, and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量。这就是我们播客的标语。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。